[Música]
olá meu nome é sofia e hoje eu vou falar
sobre - eu escolhi esse tema porque
quando tinha três anos sofreu um trauma
que me levou muito muito medo mesmo
mas agora me se eu souber o que é medo
medo é uma insegurança que você tem em
relação a algo que te impede de fazer
tocar ao chegar perto e ver se você
perder o medo depois de se vai ter outro
depois esse outro e assim em diante como
superar o medo não penso muito no futuro
nem coisas se podem acontecer com você
converse com pessoas muito próximas e
pode escrever também - que paralisam
síndrome do pânico é um tipo de medo que
paralisa e que te impede de sair de casa
você não abre a porta nem para os seus
amigos mais próximos
medo das crianças versus mesmos dos
adultos as crianças normalmente têm medo
de alturas insetos escuro palhaços e
perder familiares enquanto os adultos de
medeiros filho separar-se tempestades
perder o emprego e morreu
o gráfico de metas bolsa os medos mais
normais são cobras aranhas e alturas
você sabia que a maioria da população
tem menos medo da morte do que de
aranhas e agora você tem algum medo que
paralisa se já saiu como superar ó se
tenha um amigo com medo já saiu como
ajudá lo
[Aplausos]
[Música]